So,
good morning and thank you for joining us for this
advances session that's dedicated to gynecologic cancer
prevention. I'm Rebecca Stone and honored to serve as session
chair. Just as a brief reminder,
that you can scan the QR code at the bottom right
here, and that will allow you to ask questions
during the session. We're going to
do all the bits all at once,
and then at the end, we'll just open the big
floor for questions.
So,
today we're really going to focus on the revelation that most
ovarian cancers arise either directly or
indirectly from the fallopian tube, because this is one
of the greatest discoveries of our lifetime.
For decades, pioneer leaders like Joan Walker,
who proposed and advocated for this session, have
stood on the front lines of ovarian cancer treatment,
really working to improve outcomes, in the face of a
disease that is often diagnosed way too
late and proves deadly.
So together with Angela Belcher from MIT and
Ronnie Drebin from UPenn, we're really excited to share
these advances, marking the dawn of a prevention
era in ovarian cancer. And hopefully bringing us
closer than ever before to eliminating this disease.
And these are our collective disclosures.
So you guys get to see the first minute of a little docu-short we're making.
Here's a disease that's outsmarted us for centuries, and
we finally figured it out.
There is a big discovery in science, and it's that
most ovarian cancers don't actually start in the ovary.
They start in the fallopian tube.
And I was like, "What?" So ovarian cancer is not ovarian cancer, it's fallopian
tube cancer.
In this slide is the proof of this discovery.
See, this is what healthy fallopian tube cells look like.
But scientists found these precancerous cells, the
beginning of most ovarian cancers.
This is not an easy disease. It is brutal.
The surgeries, the chemo treatments, it is just terrible.
The reason this is such a big deal is because if you're trying to prevent
cancer, you have to be looking in the right place.
Which is why this discovery is leading to the first breakthroughs we've
seen in decades.
We see it so clearly every single day in the people we take care
of. It's impossible not to want to drop everything and work on it.
But that's really what we need to do if we are
going to close what is a very large implementation
gap between this scientific breakthrough and making
life-saving prevention an opportunity for all people,
and that's what I'm going to talk to you briefly about today.
So the graph on the right was published in "The Wall Street Journal"
25 years ago, and it cast ovarian cancer
as a disheartening outlier in the world's otherwise
encouraging progress against cancer.
In the years leading up to this article, three pivotal
developments made it possible to bend the arc toward
eliminating this disease.
The 1993 federal mandate requiring the inclusion of
women in publicly funded research in the US,
the cloning of the BRCA genes, and recognition of hereditary
ovarian cancer,
and the first observations of serous tubal intraepithelial
carcinoma, or STIC, the immediate precursor to high-grade
serous ovarian cancer in the fallopian tube.
Also in 2000, medical students like me were taught that
most ovarian cancers come from ovarian surface
epithelium, and many are still taught this today.
But we now know that less than 20% of what we have
long called ovarian cancer is actually ovarian cancer,
and you can see that in the bottom left in the teal boxes.
The rest, either directly or indirectly, comes from the
fallopian tube.
Now, the longstanding belief that ovarian cancer arises from the
ovarian surface epithelium really established
ovarian removal as the dominant risk-reducing strategy for
high-risk women with pathogenic variants like BRCA at the turn
of the century.
The fallopian tubes, though, are always removed alongside the ovaries for
practical reasons, but at the time, back then, were regarded
as a bystander organ of minimal significance.
As of today, there's still no standard prevention strategy for
average and moderate risk women.
And for high-risk women, oophorectomy is still recommended as
early as 35, triggering immediate
menopause with well-documented detriment to quality of life
and emerging long-term health consequences.
As a result, women with germline pathogenic variants in genes
like BRCA are increasingly delaying surgery beyond the
recommended age. And you can see these recent data.
About 56% of women who have a BRCA1 pathogenic variant
delay risk-reducing surgery beyond the age of 40.
And about a third of women with BRCA2 pathogenic variants
wait until after the age of 45.
And this is worrisome because we know the risk of STIC and high-grade
serous cancer rises with each passing year, and you can see that in the
bottom left.Just as important though,
a diagnosis of STIC or pre-cancer, how we currently
understand it, is not necessarily benign.
And these are data from Miranda Steenbeck and colleagues here on
the right which suggests that if STIC is already present in
the fallopian tube at the time of risk-reducing surgery
the threat of future high-grade serous peritoneal cancer is
still considerable, upwards of 30% at 10
years.
In other words, as currently practiced, surgical
prophylaxis misses the mark on prevention and interception.
What if we could offer high-risk women the intervention they need the most,
a salpingectomy, at a younger age and safely delay the
oophorectomy bit until closer to the natural age of menopause?
And that's the idea behind the international TUBAWISP-2
trial, which is actively enrolling.
And this is a preference trial that compares quality of life and
oncologic equivalence between risk reducing
salpingo-oophorectomy, the standard of care, versus
salpingectomy followed by delayed oophorectomy closer to the
natural age of menopause in high-risk women.
But only focusing prevention on high-risk women will
only get us so far.
Germline pathogenic variants are rare with a carrier
frequency collectively less than 2% and many
carriers lack family history needed to prompt genetic
testing.
We know many unfortunately first undergo genetic testing only
after their first cancer diagnosis, and this is a huge failure in
prevention and Marie Lasker called this out decades ago.
On the right, I'm showing you that 80% of women with ovarian
cancer actually have no identifiable predisposition.
We can't identify them. They're seemingly average risk.
And despite decades of trying, screening has proved
categorically ineffective. You can see here the long-term follow-up results from
the UKCTOCS trial, the largest ovarian cancer screening trial in the
history of time, and there was no difference in mortality between
screening and no screening groups.
And we often define therapeutic success by
incremental gains like months longer in remission.
Here on the right, 12 months remission with a five-drug
regimen versus 17.5 months with standard
treatment.
And so when you consider this sobering reality,
the observation that bilateral salpingectomy, removing both
fallopian tubes, reduces the risk of ovarian cancer in the general
population by at least 50% is pretty
mind-blowing.
This observation inspired what is known as opportunistic
salpingectomy, which is specifically the removal of the
post-reproductive fallopian tubes to decrease the risk of serous
ovarian cancer at the time of other abdominal surgeries
when the patient is there already in the operating room for some other
reason, incurring the risk of that primary surgery, having anesthesia,
most commonly a hysterectomy or a woman who chooses permanent
contraception and is going in for a tubal ligation,
but could be for the hundreds of thousands of other abdominal surgeries
that women have in this country every year.
And the most compelling population level effectiveness data for
opportunistic salpingectomy, really the only data so far,
have been maturing in BC, Canada since the launch of the province-wide
OVCARE initiative in 2010 under the leadership of Diane
Miller and David Huntsman, Jillian Hanley.
And by 2020 in BC, salpingectomy had largely
replaced tubal ligation and was added to 75% to
80% of hysterectomies, and you can see that in the small graphs there.
Last month, Jillian Hanley publicly announced the hazard
ratio for salpingectomy at SGO, an astounding
0.22,
evidence that opportunistic salpingectomy reduces the risk of
serous ovarian cancer by nearly 80%.
And this is the type of statistic that drives inflection points in
medicine and public health.
In the US, more than a million women choose permanent
contraception by way of tubal ligation annually, and
hundreds undergo hysterectomy or other post-reproductive abdominal
surgeries, and these represent substantial implementation
windows for integrating opportunistic salpingectomy into routine
care in our country.
However, the status quo of adoption in the US has been really
disheartening. Claims data suggests that adoption of
opportunistic salpingectomy at the time of inpatient hysterectomy has
stalled out at around 60% since 2018.
We have no idea what adoption trends are at the more common outpatient
hysterectomy because of the way claims data are in the United
States.
And data also reveals striking gaps in uptake for permanent
contraception, and you can see that there on the right.
Non-Hispanic White women are more likely to have a salpingectomy in our
country than any other racial or ethnic group.
And then the greatest implementation gap is arguably the most infuriating,
salpingectomy as an alternative to tubal ligation at the time a woman
has her last baby. This is the most common and
cost-effective episode of care for opportunistic
salpingectomy. Yet it is precisely in this setting, as you
can see there on the left, that adoption remains the
lowest, around 11% to 14%. And
in both of these cases of index and interval permanent
contraception, Black race and Medicaid insurance are
associated with a lower likelihood of
salpingectomy.And so these disparities force
us to confront a difficult truth in our country.
The implementation gap is less and less about lack of knowledge,
but more about our lack of action to care about these
statistics enough to address the germane awareness
and access barriers embedded in our healthcare system.
There are loads of recommendations to support action.
We've had them in the US for over a decade, along with growing
global consensus that opportunistic salpingectomy is an important
cancer risk-reducing strategy for average-risk women who've
completed their families and are already undergoing some other abdominal or
pelvic surgery.
And so I'll just take a moment now. We'll briefly consider what are these
barriers that really separate us from these recommendations and
universal reach of prevention?
Well, as probably most of you know, coding and health plan
coverage are bedrock access barriers, and our
existing procedure codes, the ones I use every day, are
ambiguous and disincentivizing, and they're not fit for purpose.
Health plans don't consistently include newer coverage
language for salpingectomy as a preferred alternative to
tubal ligation,
or wording that is inclusive of opportunistic salpingectomy as
an add-on procedure at non-GYN abdominal
surgery.
And beyond that, private health plans commonly impose
cost-sharing that is contrary to ACA requirements for preventive
services. And this is really apparent in
intakes from the National Women's Law Center CoverHer Hotline, and we recently
reviewed six months' worth of these from last
year. And you can see that the vast
majority of intakes here are related to lack of
coverage for salpingectomy itself when it's being offered as an
alternative to tubal ligation,
or lack of coverage of related services
like anesthesia and pathology.
And then there's health policy. Outdated health policy is
another often related major access barrier.
And many don't realize it, but in states like Maryland, where
I live, salpingectomy is still excluded from Medicaid
programs for permanent contraception.
And since private insurers often follow suit, this systematically
limits access to salpingectomy as a practical alternative to
tubal ligation.
Which is really a challenge because there's a growing body
of cost-effectiveness evidence supporting salpingectomy for
ovarian cancer prevention in the general population,
with projected costs and numbers needed to treat that are comparable
to those for HPV vaccination for cervical cancer
prevention.
And then there are the massive awareness barriers,
and these are really just profound.
Even within my own field of OBGYN, patient education
has really seemed an afterthought.
Salpingectomy is absent from most relevant sources of health
information where doctors and patients go.
Even the ubiquitous posters communicating what birth control options
are available that hang in clinics across our country, many of us
see these when we sit there cold on the exam room table waiting for our doctor,
they only show tubal ligation, and there's absolutely no mention of
salpingectomy.
We also know that for some time, providers have been performing
salpingectomy in lieu of tubal ligation without really communicating it to
patients, and you can see signs of this in online forums where
countless women, like the one here on the right, really
expose the disconnect between what they think they're choosing for contraception, a
tubal ligation, and what they get, a salpingectomy.
If they just knew about it and they were in a position to choose a salpingectomy,
not such a big deal, but when they go in thinking they're getting a tubal ligation
and someone takes out their tubes,
it's very problematic. And I bring this up because this is
really deeply concerning to me, given our country's history and
our current challenges with trust and autonomy in healthcare.
So to bridge the implementation gap between scientific discovery and
a national standard of care that's deserving of our patients and really
all of humankind in general, we started the Outsmart
Ovarian Cancer Collaborative with funding from Breakthrough Cancer in
2021. And all of the vision and work to get ovarian
cancer prevention basically to escape velocity is that of
many, many brilliant people, I'm just the one up here talking about it,
all who have joined the collaborative over the past five years.
And really exciting now in partnership with the American Cancer
Society. Okay. But where did we start?
We started at the bedrock. No codes, no coverage. Right?
So it took me two years to secure ICD-10 coding
updates through the NCHS of the CDC, and the codes that
you see here, including Z40.82 at the bottom for opportunistic
salpingectomy, went live in October, and they're in everybody's
electronic health record.
And while these are super important, coding is really just the
language of practice change. And health policy and
payer reform are really the fundamental levers.
You have to get these codes into the language of coverage
and health plans. And so, over the past couple of years, we've really put
together this coalition of influential partners where we've
taken on the heavy lift of trying to shift the
policy and reimbursement landscape towards enabling universal
coverage of opportunistic salpingectomy.
And a lot of this work has been done in my home state of Maryland, which I featured
earlier, has outdated health policy,
and includes partnership with state cancer and health commissions, the
American College of Obstetricians and Gynecologists to help advance
legislation, support from a Bloomberg Philanthropies convening
grant to engage with health plans, and collaboration with data and clinical
partners to build the infrastructure for measurement of
adoption.To work on and
overcome the awareness barriers, we've engaged community stakeholders in
co-creating knowledge mobilization solutions with guidance
from Hopkins Communication, Art as Applied to Medicine, and
patient education partners. And our ultimate goal really was
to build a comprehensive curriculum to support informed
decision-making around opportunistic salpingectomy.
And as an example, this is Abigail, who's the Outsmart medical
illustrator, and she developed the first ever set of resources to help
women better understand and clinicians to communicate the
difference between tubal ligation and salpingectomy, something so simple, but
that we were missing from our care landscape.
And now, she redid the birth control poster, and
salpingectomy appears alongside tubal ligation,
so that women see these two in the same place now.
And so these and many other first-of-kind implementation tools for patients and
providers are publicly available on our website,
outsmartovariancancer.org. You can download all of these
things completely for free. So, please visit us.
There's a way to give feedback about things that the website's missing, things you
don't like, things you like. And importantly, every
creative asset here and piece of content was carefully curated alongside
instructional design and health literacy experts in the
Outsmart collaborative over the past several years.
And the 3D animation you see here in this suite
is the cornerstone of the education module in part one of a multi-site
surgical trial that we recently activated across Hopkins, Sloan
Kettering, and MD Anderson to start to understand the acceptability,
feasibility, and safety of opportunistic salpingectomy at the time of
non-gynecologic surgery in our country.
These are surgeries like cholecystectomy, pancreatectomy, Whipple, colectomy,
urologic procedures. And as we conclude the early enrollment
period, where we've enrolled 90 patients in part one
looking at acceptability and 30 in part two looking at the
feasibility and safety of doing this at non-GYN surgery, we've
learned that most women find opportunistic salpingectomy as an
add-on to a surgery they're already having as acceptable, that
it's highly feasible right now in 100% of cases and impactful.
In just the first 30 cases, we intercepted a tubal cancer in a
woman undergoing colon surgery.
We've learned that awareness, though, has to shift upstream for
this to be really truly acceptable to people.
From the point of care, where someone's like, "Oh, now they need major surgery.
And oh, by the way, ovarian cancer is not ovarian cancer," and, "Do you want your
tubes out?" We've got to shift that to earlier nodes in a woman's
longitudinal health journey so women aren't just first considering this
when they need major abdominal surgery, but have knowledge early enough to
plan for it. And this is going to be the focus of our scaling efforts
in the coming years.
But in the background of all of this, there are these looming
unanswered questions. Why do some people still succumb
to high-grade serous cancer despite prophylactic surgery?
Well, because despite everything we've learned, there are still these
massive blind spots. We can't see fallopian
tubes, let alone these tiny little pre-cancers that start there, with any
imaging modality that is routinely used in medicine, not ultrasounds,
not CT, not MRI. We only sample a fraction of
the fallopian tube when it gets down to pathology, some estimate less than
1%, so we're apt to miss STICks and the things that really matter.
But we also don't know what to do about STICks clinically when we find them,
because we don't know which STIC lesions, which of those 30% are going
to lead to high-grade serous cancer of the peritoneum over the next 10
years. So which ones are truly dangerous?
And so with that, I'm excited to introduce Angela Belcher and Roni Drabkin,
who are really taking on these blind spots, and they're going to give you an
inside look into the progress they're making to help ensure
that ovarian cancer, the silent killer, becomes a
preventable, interceptable, and early
detectable disease.
Okay. Then you forward it just by hitting-
You can either use that or
Well, thank you, Becky, for inviting me here.
It's really amazing to be here today to talk about
some of our work in trying to find these pre-cancer lesions.
Let's see.
Let's see, start.
My name is Angela Belcher, and I'm a professor at
engineering at MIT.
Here's two pictures of my collaborators, Sangeeta Bhatia and Paula
Hammond, who I work with in ovarian cancer, and we're all holding signs that say,
"I look like an engineer."
So,
I want to talk a little bit about
finding tiny tumors. And I was
commuting and listening to a podcast, and I heard this really amazing story
that in 2020, NASA had landed a spacecraft on an
asteroid called Asteroid Bennu.
And this whole mission was like 63
million miles, and NASA sent this probe to this
moving asteroid that was about 1,600 feet across.
It circled this asteroid for like a year, took high
resolution images of it, landed on the asteroid,
collected rocks, it biopsied it, and sent them back to
Earth. And I thought, "Well, this is so amazing."
And here's pictures of it. There's real images using hyperspectral images and other
images of this probe landing on
Bennu. And I thought, "Well, this is really fascinating because we use some of the
same kind of imaging in our labs." But it's also interesting to think
in 2026, there's still no screen for ovarian
cancer. This is really unacceptable.
So we can send a probe to a moving asteroid and collect rocks, but we can't go this
far into a woman's abdomen and find a pre-cancer lesion.
And so when I give talks to the public, I always say, "What
major human feat was accomplished first?
Did we mine an asteroid or develop a screen for ovarian
cancer?" And most people think it would be develop a screen for ovarian cancer.
But this is just not
feasible right now. And so we believe that women should be able to be
screened yearly, like with mammograms or Pap smears.
And a lot of women think they're being screened for ovarian cancer when they get
Pap smears. So there's a lot of education around this.
And so, during the pandemic, I was on a Team meeting, a Zoom,
that I almost skipped because I thought, "No one will notice I'm not here."
But at the last minute, I decided to jump on, and I hear this
surgeon, Becky Stone, talking about ovarian cancer.
And one of the things she said, she goes"You know I don't know how to
always cure ovarian cancer, but I know how to prevent ovarian cancer." I'm
like, "Okay, wow. This is really, really major." And she also
went on to talk about how ovarian cancer mostly comes from the
fallopian tubes, that it's fallopian tube cancer.
And other things that are pretty remarkable about it, it starts in these p53
mutations, starts forming these pre-cancer lesions, but these pre-cancer
lesions that can sit on the end of-- This is a model of a
fallopian tube, sit on the end of this fallopian tube for nine years before
they start to spread. And so there is so much opportunity
for intervention.
Then she went on to say that
when a woman has her fallopian tubes taken out, they're embedded in wax, and then
they're cut into little sections called
a CFEM, and that the pathologist looks about 1% of
the fallopian tube. And so I didn't know her, but I was impressed by her,
and I direct messaged her in this Zoom, and I said, "We can develop an
instrument that can scan these and look at the whole fallopian tube in
about 15 minutes." And so she said, "Let's work on it together." So we
started working on it. This is showing the CFEM protocol, where they break it into
small pieces, and then they
do imaging on these sections. And so the current standard is a
little bit like looking for a needle in a haystack.
And so in my lab, what we decided to do was use something called
hyperspectral and hyperdiffuse imaging, which is used
in agriculture, nondestructive food inspection.
And we're looking mostly in near-infrared and short wavelength
infrared, where you can look deeper.
So this laser pointer I have right here, if I shine a green light on my finger, it
doesn't really go through. If I shine the red light, it goes through.
As I go further into near IR one and deeper, you can go
deeper and deeper inside the body or into a fallopian tube, for
example. And so using this hyperspectral imaging, we have many
different wavelengths of excitation and emission.
And we develop these, what are called hyperspectral cubes based on this data on a
pixel by pixel level. And what we're doing is seeing how does light
at different wavelengths interact with this tissue?
And does it look different for a cancer-based tissue or a non-cancer based
tissue? And then we use machine learning in this.
And so we've developed actually seven
instruments now, and this is our sixth generation instrument in a company I founded
called Cision Vision that has been used by thousands of patients
now for looking at lymph nodes during colon cancer treatment.
And I said, this was a review that we got.
Engineers don't understand cancer well enough to solve this problem.
We didn't get funding for it, so we built it anyway, and then we commercialized it
in less than three years in the hospital.
And so I love when people say you can't do it.
But so OVASEEK is the system that we designed in collaboration with Becky
Stone using this hyperspectral imaging, and it's basically a fallopian tube
scanner. So our original idea was that we could do this in
15 minutes. And I'm a professor, so I don't actually do anything myself.
And then talking to my students, the first couple of fallopian tubes that we looked
at took about eight hours to image.
One thing that's really, really special about
this is that we are now getting fallopian tubes
directly from the OR.
Well, let me show a little bit about this.
So there's two different ways we image, actually.
Image with just hyperspectral imaging, so just how light interacts with
tissue across many wavelengths. But we also
use nanoparticles that are fluorescent above 1,000
nanometers that have
different antibodies on them that are used for looking for these STIC or
pre-cancer lesions right now. So we do regular fluorescent scanning,
but in near-infrared,
and in IR, and we do hyperspectral imaging, and then we converge them.
So a patient undergoes a salpingectomy, a risk-reducing surgery.
They're FedExed overnight to MIT.
They have a barcode that's stitched into them.
We image them
under multiple ways. Then we fix them and we send them back to
Johns Hopkins, where they undergo regular pathology, and then we
compare results.
And so this is what the tubes look like when they come in.
Fallopian tubes are actually quite beautiful.
They're actually very, very different.
No two fallopian tubes are the same, and even the right and left look
very different. We use a method called AssetPanda,
which Becky found, and integrated it
in for this system. So we are always tracking these tubes,
and
the doctor's notes come in, the engineering
notes go out, and then they're all combined together.
So this is a whole organ imaging system.
And we've looked at 86
patients now. And here's some of the pictures of the fallopian tubes.
The black marks on them are the ink that we mark them with after we're done, where
we want the pathologist to go in and take a look.
It's just different beautiful fallopian tubes coming up.
And, of course, we're very grateful to our donors.
So we do biometrics on them. We do the weight, the length, at
different locations. We're trying to build the largest optical
database of whole fallopian tubes
across multiple imaging modalities.
We use this hyperspectral imaging.
I said before it was taking us eight hours to do, which actually made Becky very,
very nervous because I promised 15 minutes.
And so what we did was we studied a lot of different wavelengths to
figure out the best wavelengths to look at.
And when I spoke about this before, people say fallopian tubes are invisible.
You cannot see them. You can't see them by contrast enhanced CT or
MRI or by ultrasound. But they're not invisible.
You just need to know the right wavelength of excitation and emission to be able to
see them well. And so that we spent the first year really working on that.
Here's some different fallopian tubes, or some fallopian tubes with different
wavelengths, showing how they'reCertain aspects of them are more visible than
others.
And then we build these hyperspectral cubes across this, and we enter all of
this into our database.
I mentioned before that we also do fluorescence with these
nanoparticles, and then we superimpose the
fluorescence with just the plain optical data,
and add that into our algorithms. So this
is a
workflow that comes through, that we build the hyperspectral imaging, we have the
fluorescence, and then they go back to pathology.
And this was one of our very first patients that
they went back in and found this region that was less than 200
microns by
scanning a five-centimeter
fallopian tube. And, this is just showing
a breakdown of the distribution. We have 100%
enrollment. Everyone that Becky asked to
become part of our study becomes part of our study, and I'll show you a little bit
about that in the end. And they actually really like being part of this
collaboration between surgeons and engineers.
I think this one fallopian tube is from patient 66, which is myself.
I think I'm quite fond of that fallopian tube.
So this is patient ID 20. And so it's
pretty low tech. We have this image.
We mark down where we think things that look unusual to
us. We look at image, both sides of them, and then we mark it with an ink, and
then we send it back.
This is what it looks like under hyperspectral imaging.
The image is before and then after we mark the spots.
We've learned a lot in this time in terms of how
to differentiate images. And although it sounds easy, this was
our seventh-generation instrument that we built.
We've built, taken apart, rebuilt this instrument multiple times,
to be able to get the best possible data the fastest.
This is some pathology that comes back from Johns Hopkins,
where we mark this region, and they go in and they find this
atypical region,
which is mucinosis atypical differentiation.
Which I don't actually know what that is, but Becky said it's unusual and very
interesting.
This is patient 31.
Again,
going in and looking under these different imaging modalities.
And in this case,
there was a region that was thought to be a STIL, which is my understanding is like
a precursor to a STIC, and was unusual.
But was unusual enough to go back in once
we had highlighted it, to take more sections and more
cuts, and found that it actually was a STIC that was deeply
buried and wouldn't have been found if we hadn't have pointed it out
in our Overseek system.
This is different regions showing different sections that we've been able to
identify. So we use machine learning,
automated segmentation,
to look at the hyperspectral
images and the optical images. And, from our
current training data set, we have about
86% prediction in being
able to predict where the gold nanoparticles are going to bind
based on our hyperspectral imaging and looking
at those together. In order to increase the accuracy,
we think we need to get to about 300 fallopian
tubes, and so we're a little over halfway there.
We
have designed our own hardware and chips, for
edge computing.
And we call these are chips specifically for looking and for
diagnosing STICs and ovarian cancer.
This was done in collaboration with Anantha Chandrakasan,
at MIT, an engineer who's a leader in low-power chip design.
And our first chip should be coming off the assembly
line in June.
We work with Professor Kripa Varanasi at MIT,
to develop ways of collecting cells directly from these
fallopian tubes. The fallopian tubes will be on our Overseek.
And what we want to do is remove these cells, but this is part of an IRB where
we're not allowed to cut these tubes.
We're not allowed to make any changes to these tubes that are going to affect
the diagnosis for the patient, for the pathologist.
So Kripa Varanasi is a really brilliant engineer.
He developed so many interesting things, but one of them is actually how do you get
all the ketchup out of the ketchup bottle or all the toothpaste out of the
toothpaste tube?
But he also designed these shear-free capturing systems.
We call it the
iCollector, where he goes in, and we collect
cells off these regions.
And that's been very successful. From
that,
then we can
start cell cultures from this, and we can start organoids.
From these patient-specific organoids, we started doing this around patient
31. These are my organoids that are
growing right here. And so now we
can
study and understand these as a function of
pre-treatment for therapeutics and as a function of
genetic mutations.
Here's some fallopian tubes that are grown from patients from wild type versus
BRCA
organoids, as well as what our wild type look after several
passages.
So, a really special part of this is that we've been collaborating to
let patients be very involved in the study, and this is one of the reasons why we
think we have 100% of the patients that we reach out
to
join this study.And this is a technology called
deBI or decentralized biobanking.
It's a virtual lab for patients,
scientists, and physicians. And this was
developed, really the brainchild of Mariel Grose at Johns
Hopkins and Pitt. And so all of our patients
can watch their samples. And
as they leave the OR, as they arrive to
MIT, they can see what the fallopian tubes look like within a couple of days
in their bio wallet. They can see their cells, they can see the
organoids that are developed,
and they can communicate with the engineers to
learn about what's happening to their cells, what's happening with their
organoids, and can really feel ownership,
and know that their cells were being used in a useful
way to help other women in the future.
So it started with an IRB. We have the only IRB in the world that we think,
where we can send fallopian tubes directly from the OR to
engineers
not too far away. And so for three years, we've looked at 160
fallopian tubes. We developed imaging technology,
nanoparticles.
We developed our own AI, ML algorithms, and our own chips,
a way of doing cell collection, and now we have this organoid
biobank.
We said we're looking where no one could look before.
I'm really honored to go talk right before
Ronnie. I'm looking forward to his talk.
Ronnie and I were in a museum in New York, maybe
it was about a year and a half ago,
and Ronnie looks like a really nice guy.
He is a really nice guy, but he's kind of tough too.
And so I was talking about it and he goes, "Yeah, you can do that, but can you look
at single cells, and can you see single mutations?" And I was
like, "I don't know. This guy's tough." But doing that,
we went back into the lab, and we started developing
technology, both hardware and
algorithms, to try to address some of
Ronnie's questions. And these questions were, what we want to be able to do
is not only look at whole fallopian tubes, we want to look at
whole fallopian tubes, but down to the single-cell level
and even intracellularly, and be able to tell something about
it. So we're not there yet, but we have
been working on technology to two different things.
One is to be able to determine a BRCA mutation or
not just based on how that tissue interacts with
light,
and do that for other kinds of mutations as well.
And this is just some initial data from a study of Ronnie's
with wild type and BRCA1 and BRCA2 patients
in their fallopian tubes. And we've
been able to train models that can, with 90% accuracy,
tell whether a patient has BRCA1 mutation or 2 mutation
or wild type just by how it interacts with light.
And we've been able to do that at the cellular level as well.
At the cellular level for different kinds of mutations, I can't get into a lot
today, we have about a 95% accuracy looking at live
cells or tissues or organoid sections as well, and we
validated that over about 5,000 images.
Ten mutations, 26 variants, and four different cancer types.
So, like I said before, I'm just here talking about this.
This is the team of amazing people that have worked really
hard to make this happen, and I finished early, which has never happened
before. I thank you for your attention.
And I have these fallopian tubes. If you really want a fallopian
tube model, I don't really want to take these home.
So I have six up here. Some in teal for
ovarian cancer and some in pink. So feel free to help yourself to
those. Thank you.
Okay, great. That's always hard to follow Angie.
What an amazing talk.
So it's a privilege and honor to actually be in this session
with both Becky and Angie, talking about what's the latest in our
understanding of these pre-cancers in the fallopian tube.
You've already heard about the tubal hypothesis, the seeking, and
trying to identify pre-cancer lesions.
What I'm going to start off with is a little bit of a recap of that, but focusing
on the tools that led us to understanding that the fallopian tube is
the place we should be focusing our energy.
And that was in particular about 20 years ago now, the development of the SEFIM
protocol by Chris Crum, who happened to be my clinical mentor.
And it was really the development of this protocol that led us to really hone in
on the fimbriated end of the fallopian tube as the business end.
It enabled us to characterize the lesions.
You've heard of STIC already, which is the in situ carcinoma, the P53 signature,
which are benign-looking secretory cells, so that's your target cell that
harbors alterations in P53. And then subsequent studies over the
years by many groups have added additional contextual
understanding to what happens in these lesions as you progress from
benign to malignancy, including the presence of DNA damage,
mutations in P53, and copy number alterations, which are the
hallmark of this cancer.
That was followed by whole exome, whole genome sequencing studies by a number of
groups that really gave us the chronology of the disease, the timeframe,
essentially, that we should be thinking about as you progress from benign to
malignancy. And I think the takeaways we're all familiar with are P53
mutations are the only recurrent somatic alteration in this disease.
It's an obligatory event, and it's also one of the
earliest, if not the earliest event.Copy number alterations are also early and
really define this disease. And then the timeframe from an in situ
carcinoma STIC lesion to an invasive cancer is about 6.5 years, which is
a number that's been verified at least in two independent
studies. Unfortunately, once these cancers make it to the ovary, it progresses
rather rapidly to involve the peritoneal cavity within one to two years.
Now, the implications of this, you already heard about, right?
SEAFM protocol is important, right?
That should be used in the assessment of all risk-reducing surgeries.
Opportunistic salpingectomy is already proving out to be an incredible
tool for reducing the incidence of ovarian cancer.
And then for the high-risk individuals of the BRCA1 and 2 mutations,
this is being explored through three international clinical
trials. You heard about WISP and tuba2, the NRG study here in
the US, and the Protector UK study in the UK.
So I wish you could stop here and say that isn't it great we
found out where this cancer comes from, and now we have changed the way we think
about prevention, right? Salpingectomy, and pat ourselves on the back.
But as usual, things are never that simple.
I'm going to illustrate this with a few cases.
So here's a 46-year-old female patient with a BRCA1
mutation, comes in for risk-reducing surgery.
Pre-menopausal, CA125 ultrasound are normal, but she is found
to have a STIC at risk-reducing surgery.
And unfortunately, almost 10 years after the removal of this STIC,
she develops peritoneal carcinomatosis, disease all
over the peritoneal cavity. Fortunately, the
original STIC lesion was retrieved, as was the blocks for the
peritoneal carcinomatosis. They were sequenced and found to have the exact same
P53 mutation, strongly arguing that they were related and that this
was actually a recurrence of the original STIC lesion.
The second patient is a 53-year-old female, also BRCA1
mutation carrier.
Pre-menopausal, had breast cancer in the past, but her CA125 and ultrasound
were normal, and she's also found to have a STIC lesion, but 80
months later, also develops peritoneal carcinomatosis.
In this case, the sequencing of the original STIC and the carcinomatosis was shown
to have a frameshift mutation, which gives you sort of a null phenotype, so you
can't stain well for P53. It looks negative in the STIC,
but also in the cancer.
And this was, as Becky pointed out, really the point was brought
home with the Steenbeck paper published in 2022, which looked at over
3,000 patients from which 115 STICs were
identified, and the important part is that the clinical follow-up,
right? And they argued, and they showed that if you have a STIC at
risk-reducing surgery, your risk of developing widespread disease at five or
10 years later was almost 11 and 28%, much
higher than people had thought. And it argued that STICs
carry markedly increased risk of later peritoneal carcinomatosis, right?
So this is a real problem, especially when you think about in situ disease.
It hasn't invaded the basement membrane, so once you cut it out, you think you'd be
done. This says not so.
It also argues and begs the question, are all STICs created equal?
So here are examples, H&E on the left and
immunohistochemistry for P53 here on the right.
I hope you can appreciate that the STIC lesion on the top left is very different
looking than the STIC lesion on the bottom left.
The STIC lesion on the top looks very discohesive.
It's shedding cells into the lumen.
You can actually appreciate these P53 positive cells in the lumen,
whereas the bottom STIC seems to be more well-behaved.
And my colleague Yiming Shi at Hopkins has defined the term
BLAD for budding loosely adherent and detached or FLAT,
and has actually argued that the FLAT STIC lesions not only look
different, but are not as proliferative as the BLAD lesions.
And it's really important to know whether certain STIC lesions are different and
have different clinical potential because we know that not all precursors
are going to become a cancer. Think about cervical carcinoma when we think
about CIN1, CIN2, and CIN3. CIN1 lesions we
oftentimes observe because some of them regress.
CIN3 lesions were sent to colposcopy.
So it's really important to understand which lesions are the ones we need to worry
about.
Moreover, there are many things about these precursors that we still don't
understand, right? So what are the features of the microenvironment that actually
influence STIC behavior? Is that something that we need to think about?
What about epigenetics, proteomics, metabolomics?
What's the impact of a BRCA1 mutation on the tubal epithelium, and how
does this all influence our thinking about early detection and cancer
interception? And so a number of years ago, we decided to explore
these questions by developing a deeper understanding of our
knowledge in the fallopian tube itself and in the progression from benign to
malignancy by looking at a cohort of patient
samples that were well annotated and were going to be molecularly
characterized. So these studies were published last year.
This is the fallopian tube study. I think this is the largest collection of human
fallopian tubes that have been evaluated by multi-omic
approaches. And the pre-cancer atlas, as we
call it, where we've done spatial proteomics and transcriptomics
across the continuum from benign to malignancy.
I'm going to first focus on the pre-cancer atlas, but I'm going to come back to the
fallopian tube atlas towards the end.
So this study,
as most big studies, it's a multi-institutional,
multi-investigator effort. It takes a lot of work and commitment by a lot of
people. I have to say this is probably one of the most fun collaborations I've ever
been a part of. Peter Sorger, Sandro Santagata really led the
charge with incredibly talented postdoc T*****a
Kader, who's actually in the back, I see her, and a talented
bioinformatician and computational biologist, Jerry Lin.
And it was really taking advantage of technologies that had been evolving over the
last 10 years, where we could do multiple
immunofluorescence or multiplex immunofluorescence on a single section of tissue,
FFPE tissue, and then on a consecutive section, do multi-regional whole
transcriptomics. So you can really capture the cell state at the protein level
and the expression level of the various different...
genes in those cells. These are the antibody panels
that were developed for the spatial proteomics.
Importantly, most of the cases came from Penn and the University of
Fred Hutch Cancer Center in Seattle.
And I think really the point of creating an atlas is to make this
data available to the broader community, and so all the data has been deposited in
the cBioPortal. I think it's the first data set in the cBioPortal that
has image analysis as well. So you can explore not just the
gene expression data, but you can actually go into every individual case,
look at the regions of interest that we explored, look at the different levels of
expression of the immune system or whatever marker you're interested, both in the
epithelial and in the stromal component. So what did we learn?
Well, first, the key to a lot of this is making sure that the tissue you have
is what you think you have. So we did central pathology review to make sure
that we had P53 signatures, incidental STIC
lesions, and STICs associated with invasive disease.
We collected all the relevant epidemiologic and clinical
data from these patients, so BRCA status, race, ethnicity, where
the cases were harvested, which technologies were
applied to all these cases.
And the cohort essentially was 43 patients.
We had 44 samples from these 43. Most of them were treatment naive.
And we were able to collect a tremendous amount of data at the single-cell level
for all of these.
What did we learn? There's a lot of data. This is published.
I'm not going to dwell on that very much.
But just to summarize that, one of the earliest observations we made was that
interferon signaling emerges in the P53 signature
but then gradually shifts towards a more chronic, incessant
signaling that we are quite familiar with.
And here's acute versus chronic interferon signaling can tip
the balance from anti-tumor to a more pro-tumorigenic
microenvironment. And so this is one of the things that led us to
appreciate that as these lesions progress from
signature to
STIC lesion to invasion, we see an accumulation of strong
immunosuppressive and remodeling modules, and we think that
the transition point that marks malignancy is once that
STIC lesion invades.
Now, my colleague, Yiming Shi, in a very complementary and parallel effort,
did a similar analysis across a whole set of STIC lesions that he explored,
and using gene expression, morphology, and aneuploidy, defined four
different types of STICs that they can annotate.
And I asked him, because I wanted to share this data with the group.
Like the effort we had with cBioPortal, he created a portal to be able
to explore the genes of interest that the
community may have. And so you can use this QR code.
It'll take you to his data set, and you can type in your favorite gene,
and it'll tell you what's the status of that gene as you go from benign to
malignancy. So this is great, and I think we're
learning quite a bit about the molecular features of these pre-cancers.
But what's missing, and I think ultimately what is critical for us to be able
to say which STIC lesions are problematic, which ones do we have to actually
act on quickly versus not, because you don't want to over-treat everyone,
is that we need the clinical annotation linked to these molecular
attributes. And so to do that, we've fortunately gotten
funding to expand our atlas work. We call this Atlas 2.0.
We've created a STIC network with multiple sites across the US,
Europe, the Middle East, and more recently, Nigeria, where we have
centers that are going to be contributing samples to the Precancer
Atlas. And through a REDCap database, we're going to be collecting all the clinical
history from all these patients so that we will have, over time,
acquired all the features and the important clinical outcomes that we're going
to be able, and are going to need, to be able to say, "A STIC lesion
with these particular features
is a bad outcome, and you need to act now," versus a
STIC lesion that may be more indolent.
Perhaps you don't have to do over-treatment.
So I think this is an important piece that we're quite excited to explore.
Now,
this multimodal imaging that I've described to you, cyclic
immunofluorescence and spatial transcriptomics, have
given us unprecedented insights into tissue
architecture, tumor cell states, microenvironment,
immune engagement
in these early lesions. But when we think about the
genomic context in the context of the cell state, we don't
have a tool that enables us to do that.
Most of the time, we're inferring genomic context in these settings from other
methodologies, like RNA expression patterns or from a consecutive section of
tissue, which is not necessarily aligned or in register with the
section that you're working with.
And this is particularly important because copy number changes, like I said, are
the hallmark of ovarian cancer, even early on.
And so to address this limitation, the
Sorger and Santagata labs developed a platform called Orion
Fish, which takes advantage of being able to do
one-shot 16 to 18 plex immunofluorescence on the
tissue section while using a morphology-preserving
algorithm that enables you to do DNA-FISH on that same
section. So you can do 16 to 18 markers for protein
state and up to four markers for FISH.
Now, fortunately for everybody, Tangena is here with us, and she has
her poster this afternoon, Poster 3533.
I encourage you to go there. She'll set you straight about all the things I got
wrong. But what I want to share with you today is this incredible platform
is really revealing some interesting insights into the earliest
genesis of this cancer. So we started initially with high-grade serous
ovarian cancer to really profile the system, make sure it
works well. And then we moved into STIC lesions and even
normal tissues to see what's happening at the genomic level when we can
actually have the protein state, the cell state, and the
genomics all in the same section.Now,
I am reminded here that this paper was just released last night, I
think. And the editor provided this QR code so
that it would coincide with this meeting, and you can access the paper through this
QR code.
Okay, so we began first, as I mentioned, by validating this Orion FISH platform
on high-grade serous cancers. We used an independent
validation for copy number assessment using BioView, which is a
clinically approved automated FISH scoring platform.
We think this is rather important because if this can ultimately make it to the
clinic, we now have a tool that we validated our
approach with to really
call out the copy number patterns.
Now, here's one example of a STIC lesion where we looked
at the 16 and 18 markers I mentioned, and we looked at
two particular oncogenes that are amplified in ovarian cancer.
One is MYC, which is the most commonly amplified oncogene in ovarian cancer,
chromosome eight. And the other is cyclin E, which is often
very amplified, always associated with poor outcomes on chromosome 19.
So that's two out of the four. The other two are the centromeric controls for each
of them, chromosome eight and chromosome 19.
And what we noted, which was kind of a surprise, was that in any
STIC lesion where you see amplification, let's say for MYC,
it never happens as a monoclonal growth.
There wasn't just MYC gains or amplifications in these
lesions. There were regions that had MYC amplification and cyclin E
amplification and regions that had both in the STIC lesion, which was
a bit surprising. So we get this polyclonal structure to STIC lesions
rather than a single
dominant copy number state.
And what was also interesting is that the MYC amplified
or gained regions tended to be more associated with immune
cells in the neighborhood of those amplified
cells, whereas the cyclin E seemed to be more devoid of immune cells
in those regions.
What we also noted in the top left here, here we're exploring the STIC
lesion on the bottom right of this image here, but there was also normal
epithelium adjacent to it. And you see these two bars that
we
highlight here.
We noted that in the normal-looking epithelium, while we were looking for
cyclin E gains or amplification in the STIC lesion, we noted that there
are epithelial cells that show
copy number gain in what is ostensibly normal tubal
epithelium. Similarly, in the other box here,
we saw evidence of MYC amplification in normal-appearing
epithelial cells. And as I mentioned before, the
MYC
copy number altered cells tended to have more immune cells
associated with them
than the cyclin E altered cells. Right?
And again, this was validated by BioView imaging and quantification.
Right? Suggesting that there's something happening in normal epithelium
at the genomic level that we didn't necessarily appreciate
before. Maybe perhaps normal is sort of a
relative term. And to explore this more carefully, we went back to the
fallopian tube atlas, the Bedos paper.
We took 30 benign fallopian tube epithelial cells, and we
applied our Orion FISH to that.
To look at
a particular genomic event, right?
We could look at cyclin E, we could look at MYC, but we also wanted to look at
lesions that aren't typically associated with ovarian cancer to see whether this is
permissive of any genetic alteration, whether there was a constraint placed
upon which genetic events are tolerated.
And so we looked at
Mdm4 on chromosome one, and what we found was
that indeed, there was evidence of
Mdm4 copy number gain, both in the
PAX8-positive secretory cells and the FOXP1
positive ciliated cells. And this is quantified here on the
left. We noted more of this in the BRCA1 mutation carrier
tubes than we did in the BRCA2 or average-risk
individuals.
Now, I think it's worth noting, and we were
motivated to look at this in part because there was some really nice data in
breast cancer. Joan Brugge and Sam Aparicio had published a nice paper in "Nature
Genetics"
showing that benign breast epithelium in BRCA
mutation carriers have rare cells that show copy number
alterations, in particular for chromosome 1Q, Mdm4.
And those alterations occur in the luminal cells, but not
in the myoepithelial cells. So
suggesting that there's a selectivity to what cells are affected by this.
And it just so happens that in breast cancer, Mdm4 chromosome 1Q gains or
amplifications are common in the cancers that ultimately emerge from that,
right? What we're seeing in the fallopian tube is that there's no preference for
which cell type is affected by this.
It's ciliated cells, it's secretory cells, and more importantly, once we
look at the p53 signatures,
these alterations are competed out.
It appears that these are stochastic events that don't necessarily contribute
to cancer development. They occur, but once you get that p53
mutation, they're competed out.
Okay. So brief summary. STIC lesions are heterogeneous.
Interferon signaling is one of the early events that we see in the fallopian
tube precursors that's associated with immune evasion and
protumorigenic properties. There's pronounced single-cell
heterogeneity in MYC and cyclin E copy number states within a STIC.
So again, it's polyclonal, it's not monoclonal.
And we think that this probably reflects the fact that there are multiple genetic
trajectories that coexist in the pre-cancer state.
Local immune organizations track with certain epithelial copy number states
rather than abundance of cells alone.
And rare epithelial cells with elevated gene-specific signals,
like Mdm4 that we looked at, exist in morphologically normal
epithelium, but again, they're distinct from p53
signatures.Local immune organization appears to be
genotype associated, meaning there's something about a MYC amplified or
MYC gained cell versus a secondly amplified cell,
and maybe this leads to the sculpting of these precursors in the
fallopian tube. Okay, so with that, I'll end.
I'll just thank the folks in the lab and collaborators, in particular,
Sandra, Peter, T*****a, Jerry. Couldn't have done any of this without them.
Our funding sources, obviously the patients who've donated their tissues
and the STIC network that we've been able to pull together to look at this,
hopefully with the goal of having an analysis and understanding of
pre-cancers that really spans a broad female population, so we could
actually use that data ultimately for early detection and
interception. Thank you for your time.
Okay. Well, we'd love to open it up to questions,
comments. We have a couple in the chat, but we'll take the live floor
first.
Hi, thanks very much. Really interesting session.
I'm Paul Ferrer from Cedars-Sinai.
I'll summarize really briefly what I think the story that you're telling.
So we can remove fallopian tubes and reduce the risk,
but we know that it doesn't prevent entirely and that there is still a
risk of future
serous carcinoma, peritoneal serous carcinoma.
So what you want to identify
is the STIC lesions that are predictive of that.
But my question is, and maybe this is the wrong people to ask, but actually what
are you going to do about that? Because what's the intervention?
So you say to somebody, "Ooh, look, you've got a terribly high risk STIC here.
You're going to get ovarian cancer in 10 years' time." What's
the
next step, and are we on a way to actually
being able to do something?
I'm happy to take that. As a clinician GYN oncologist up
here,
I think that that is the next most
important question.
And, we have to be able to reliably find STIC, right?
Many times we remove fallopian tubes, the patient gets a path report, they're
normal, right? And then they end up with high-grade serous cancer in two years,
and we go back and look at the tubes and we're like, "Ugh, there was a missed STIC
there," right?
And so we have to understand,
in order to design a trial like that, it's important I think that we
have to quench this next question as to which do we think are
the aggressive STICs, right? Because those are the patients that need to go on
at least some increased surveillance or some sort of STIC
interception
protocol. And what that should be,
I don't know. We have a number of thoughts about that.
I'm curious-
PARP inhibitors might be a potential.
PARP inhibitors might be an option.
Chemo.
Yeah. Anything
from GLP-1 agonist is an interesting
idea. Some people have thought about making STIC vaccines.
So I think that is where this is hopefully
heading.
And I think, on my side of it, of opportunistic salpingectomy in the general
population, I think all of this emphasizes
why,
if we're going to work on prevention, this really needs
to be in populations before they develop a STIC, right?
And we know that that risk increases after age 50, if you
look at the data from Denmark. And so,
it's really important to focus on these populations of women so that they
understand they could choose a salpingectomy instead of a tubal ligation.
And that's the age range where, if you're going to choose
prevention, it's probably the best.
Okay. Hi.
Really great work. It's a great session.
I'm Timi Gutusch from Mercy Ben Analytics. I have a comment and a question.
So comment is, Dr. Belcher showed on her slide that there's no
ovarian cancer screening assay available.
That's actually our test is in early access this
year and probably more widely available later this year.
And the question is--
Thank you. And the question is, in the UK, they
decided to implement CA 125 screening for high
risk
patients. What's your thought on that? It's in the NICE guidelines.
What are your thoughts about that?
I think, CA 125 screening,
I have not seen a patient who has
what seems to be a risky STIC,
have an elevated CA 125 or anything detectable.
And so it makes me nervous because
with anything, we're able to maybe
detect the disease before someone has symptoms,
but the patient still has Stage 3 cancer,
and a limited poor prognosis. So,
until someone can show me some population level
data that CA 125 or any screening test can
find the disease
when it is limited to the tube and this
seven to nine year period before it disseminates in the peritoneal
cavity, I'm not certain that we will really be able to
impact mortality.
Mm-hmm. So I mean, if you look at the
UK CTOCS trial and you take out the-
Mm.
... prevalent round, there is actually a
mortality benefit. But they didn't report that because it wasn't
pre-specified, right? So-
Right.
Yeah.
Problem with that, and I love that, that you're pointing that out because I think
it's important, so that's when they separate out the high-grade serous
patients.
Mm-hmm.
But what's fascinating, if you look at the curves in that
exploratory analysis, is that there's no
benefitAt 5, 10, 15 years.
You have to live to 18 years or longer to get that
mortality benefit from screening.
Mm-hmm.
That's where the curves start to separate in terms of benefit versus no
benefit. And unfortunately, as someone who takes care of ovarian cancer
patients, I don't have too many of them that live to 15 or 18
years.
Okay. Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
Great. Hi. Thank you. This is a question for Dr. Drapkin.
The acute versus chronic interferon, I think, is really, really interesting,
and the fact that you see in the most recent data the MYC
amplification associated with more immune cell infiltration.
Often, there's an antagonistic relationship between MYC signaling and type one
interferon. I was curious about what types of immune cells were there and what you
think is going on.
Yeah, these are mostly CD8 T cells, activated CD8 T
cells. We looked at CD4 too. I think T*****a could correct me in the back,
but I think it was mostly CD8 positive.
Okay. Thank you.
Hi, I'm Ahmed. I'm a gyn onc fellow at Walter Reed, right next door to you, Dr.
Stone, and also MIT
Course 9. So my question is, as you were talking about
sending the tubes up to MIT and doing that special imaging,
as someone who rotates at three different hospitals and sees the
vast difference in quality of frozen pathology, if you're thinking
about that as the next step, because I could see that being very
advantageous in terms of making intraoperative decision makings and kind of
smoothing out the variability curve in frozen pathology. Thank you.
Yeah. So you're talking about scaling, essentially
OVASEEK imaging to the pathology lab.
And I think that-
Other organs.
Yeah. Ideally, we would get OVASEEK in the path lab,
so we don't have to send the tubes, because I do think
it's a very special protocol. It was a very challenging IRB to get
approved because essentially it is a change
in standard chain of custody for a path specimen.
So, we had to get IRB approval to interrupt the
typical chain of custody when a surgical specimen is removed
and goes directly to the path lab downstairs.
Instead, the patients who consent to this protocol are
agreeing to have their tube sent up to MIT, go
through this imaging protocol, and then come back to Hopkins.
And so
when we started this, I was a little worried.
Was I going to end up in fallopian tube jail, so to speak- ...
for this? Because I didn't know. I
had, relatively speaking, just met Angie, and it's been
an incredible collaboration where, like Angie said, every single patient
understands this unmet need. When you tell someone, "Well, you realize that
under typical histopath, the tube goes down, and the
pathologist maybe looks at 1% to 3% of it before issuing a path report,"
patients understand that, and especially patients who are high risk.
And so we've started now to have people coming to Hopkins to be on this
protocol because they want this added layer of imaging.
And every single tube has come back
and been examined by the same pathologist between
Russell Vang and Yiming Shi, who are really the world's experts in looking at
fallopian tubes. So
I just want to emphasize it's
very specialized, with some of the best pathologists in the world.
And so we have to get it to the point, I think, where the instrument
can be in the path lab. I don't know.
So yeah, thank you for that question.
We're
probably about a year away from locking down our
final prototype for the OVASEEK.
And
we
had started out with a very expensive laser and
detection systems, where I said it was also taking eight
hours.
And now we have
kind of drilled down into what the right excitation
and emission wavelengths are to get the data that we want to be able to get.
And so it is our vision also that it would be more in the path lab.
Another company that I founded, Cision Vision,
it's a tool that is in pathology that works between the
surgeons and the pathologist for zeroing in on a region
for pathology for colon cancer. So I think in a year we'll
lock down our prototype and then
look at how to expand that. But we've had several
hospitals in this country and other countries ask us for a prototype.
Yeah, great talk.
I just had a quick question for Dr. Drapkin.
So the other gene on 1q that is of
interest is CHD1L. It's a chromatin remodeler.
Priyanka at Wash U has demonstrated some nice work in terms
of its role in MMEJA activity. Is there any effort
to understand the chromatin
structure of these STIC lesions that have the 1q
amplification, as well as looking at DNA repair
signatures?
That's a great question. I think that's an obvious sort of place to go
with this type of data, right? We haven't specifically looked at it, but I think it
makes a lot of sense. I actually kind of wonder
what Angie described about being able to
discern BRCA status from the imaging.
Chromatin status is manifest in DAPI staining and things like that,
whether you'd be able to sort of pick up some of these sort of
alterations like a CH-
I was going to show you that during lunch.
Yeah.
But perhaps that approach. Obviously, I think there's interesting
biology underlying that as well. But yeah, we haven't looked yet, but it's a good
one.
Hi, my question is for Dr. Belcher.
You had mentioned that for the organoids that you got from the cells
from the fallopian tubes, that you were able to keep them for multiple passages,
and I was just curious how long they survive in culture.
So that's a question for my graduate student.
But I know
that we've-- I don't know if you're talking about number of passages or
number of months that we've been having them.
Right now, the ones that I showed today that were
my organoids, those are from November.
But yeah, I can text my graduate student and ask, but I don't actually even know
how to do that myself.
Can you
freeze and thaw them?
Organoids?
Yeah, we have freeze and thaw.
Okay.
We have done that.
Hi, I'm Christopher Bolus, a medical oncologist.
I have a strong clinical interest in DCIS.
So my question is, are STICs exclusively
found in the fimbriated end? And what's
different-- So they're less frequent in the tube. Are they different?
Do they have a different outcome?
That's a good question.
Most of the studies that have
used a CFIM protocol have documented greater than 93% of the
lesions in the fimbriated end. I don't know of a study
that's compared ones, that small percent that are not, whether
they're different in terms of outcome.
You could certainly imagine a STIC lesion that's further in the tube might actually
present as a primary tubal carcinoma, which we think of as exceedingly
rare. That's why no one ever paid much attention to it.
But most of them are in the fimbriated end.
So in the breast, about 20% start in the duct.
Both start in the TDLU. That's very interesting. Thank you.
I'll just follow up and say our imaging technology picks up
regions outside the fimbriated end.
But we haven't fully characterized them in terms of pathology to
understand if they're STICs and what kind of STICs they are.
But because we scan the whole fallopian tube, we find regions of
interest that do interact with some of the antibodies that
are used for STICs. And we pick up interesting optical
spectra, but we
don't have enough data yet to comment on that in detail.
This next question is for Dr. Stone.
My name is Sarah Lino, I'm a GYN oncologist in Cleveland, but I trained in
Maryland, so I'm very familiar with the transition that the GBR
had on the state market. My question is, so we're more of
a capitation-driven market where I'm at now, and short
of convincing my peers to do the right thing in terms of
opportunistic salpingectomy, what's the best way to advocate on a systems
level to make sure that we're encouraging
all potential opportunities moving forward?
Yeah. Thank you so much for that. Do you say you're at Cleveland Clinic,
is that right?
I'm at University Hospitals.
Okay, University Hospitals.
Just starting to do it, but they also have not yet implemented it.
Yeah.
So a lot of it is coming down to reimbursement driven issues.
Yeah, that's so interesting. So,
we have this first sort of wave or phase of implementation
that we're launching in the US, and actually Cleveland Clinic is at that
table. And were one of the first people that approached us.
But this is a number of different sites across the United States that are really
interested in support to do this. And the way
that I think about it is,
and how we're going to do it, and if anybody is interested
in being part of this first wave, please, I'll stay
afterwards, come up and we are happy to include you,
is that there are sort of two issues.
One is, are you optimizing
the opportunities in OBGYN? And really
being able to drill down on that pretty quickly so that when
we look to unsilo it from OBGYN to general surgery, that we're like, "Well,
we've optimized it on our side.
This is what we learned from doing that," or, "We're already really good." And like
Cleveland Clinic, when we
brought this up, said, "We can guarantee we've optimized it. We've looked at this.
We have our data." We're to the point where if you do a
tubal ligation instead of a salpingectomy for permanent contraception, it has to be
documented in the operative note as to why that was.
So that's pretty granular. And we went through the same thing at
Hopkins, where we were at 13% adoption or
something like that.
And we're a five-hospital system, and there are many reasons for lack of adoption
that are very reasonable, and to your point, have to do with the economics
of your hospital system, the economics of your state, policy,
all these things.
The billing and coding. So there's a lot that
goes into this, a lot to think about that many people didn't think about, like how
are we going to deal with this 30-day wait for Medicaid patients, right?
So that's why we want to do it as a collaborative, a national
collaborative, so we're all at the table, and it's sort of a
learning experience. And then the idea is, and American Cancer Society is
supporting this, they're at that table too, supporting it from a policy advocacy
implementation and research standpoint, so that as we are all around
this table, what are the new questions that come up, either on the science
side or all the way on the late phase
translational health side.
Thank you.
I kind of wonder whether--
I remember seeing a map that David or Jillian showed.
So a lot of this started in British Columbia,
and the take there has been quite substantial, but if you look
across Canada, it's kind of all over the place, and I'm wondering whether we
could learn something from what have the barriers beenIn a
country where they've already started this well over a decade or so ago,
is there something-- I mean, very different systems, but implementation seems to
be such a challenging aspect, right?
Think about HPV vaccination rates across this country, right?
There's a lot of that. What can we learn from experiences up in Canada that might
help us down here?
Yeah. Jillian and I, we talk pretty regularly about this.
I actually called her
when we were starting to think about this a couple of years ago, and I was like,
"Jillian, what was the implementation rollout plan here?" And she's like, "Oh,
it was just Diane Miller was just such a force." And so,
really,
how amazing, really, with mostly Diane's leadership and
OvCare and David and Jillian, they've gotten it this far.
And I'm sure,
David Huntsman is sitting right here.
I would love to invite him up to comment on this, honestly,
because I think one of the biggest
problems in the US compared to Canada is that we don't have
a nationalized healthcare system.
And measuring adoption is a real problem
because I'll give you one example.
When you look at claims data lakes for salpingectomy, the
most common scenario is somebody having their tubal ligation or their
tubes out at
having their last baby. The codes are ambiguous.
It's the same code for a tubal ligation as it is for salpingectomy.
There's no incentive for somebody to do a salpingectomy instead of a tubal
ligation.
And
even when a salpingectomy is done, in most states, in most
systems, it's billed as a tubal ligation because the health plan
doesn't recognize the coding that's submitted for the salpingectomy.
So you can't actually drill down on this using claims data.
So we've had to use AI and build some LLMs and that sort of thing, which we've
done, which is part of this collaborative.
The idea is then to take that
and to
test it out, validate it, and use it as a way for people to measure
adoption in OBGYN. It's not such a big deal in general surgery, because
once you see tubes coming out with a gallbladder, it's pretty easy to pick that up.
But in terms of really knowing whether we've optimized the opportunity in
OBGYN, which we must do. We cannot just move into general surgery and
forget about our own field, because that is where the lion's share of opportunity
is. And so as part of the collaborative, we're going to work together on
building a way to measure adoption and track it so
we know how well we're doing, and I think that's really important.
That'll be happy.
I would love to chat.
Kind of related to the previous discussion about high-risk STICs, is there enough
known about the cells that are poised to shed or
beginning to shed or have shed in terms of their genomics or
epigenetics or anything that could
use in a more of a earlier detection or
cell-free DNA or anything in the
rare-seq or any other ways to look at this?
Right. So Yiming is using, I think he calls it SafeSeq,
trying to define
aneuploidy in some of these.
I don't think there's enough data.
Certainly, cycline amplified cells tend to be
among the ones that look like BLAD as opposed to FLAT.
Mm-hmm.
And that's always an aggressive biology across any solid tumor that you
look at. But I don't think we have enough, and certainly no one's sampled
those detached or poised to detach cells to see what
their features are. The technology, I think, exists.
With spatial imaging, you could do some of that to see what are the
characteristics of those.
The other thing I was hoping someone would bring up
is
the recent work in pancreas and in fallopian tube
from Denny Wirtz, Laura Wood at Hopkins, where
one of the
beautiful things about the CFRIEM protocol is that it actually led us to look at
the right place.
But it's sort of come up a few times, which is that still
histology, I'm a pathologist, and I'm comfortable
dissing the fact that when you're looking at a three-dimensional problem in two
dimensions, you're going to miss things.
And if you actually take and level an entire block for
pancreas or tube, it turns out that the rate of precursor
lesions is much higher than we all thought.
So we all have panin lesions in our pancreas with KRAS mutations,
by the way, ew.
But most of them don't progress. And so the fact that they're
more common doesn't bother me. I think it still comes back to figuring
out which are the problematic ones.
And then to Paul's point, what are you going to do about them?
Initially, when we started
signing out STIC lesions at the Brigham, this is like 2005 and
2006, and Judy Garber would come to us and like, "What am I supposed to do with
this?" And some people started giving chemo and then backed off.
But I think once we have a more granular understanding of which ones are the
problematic ones, you could start thinking about chemo or PARP
inhibitors or something, because you got to do something.
Whereas the other ones, you're not going to put them through that.
And I think that's what we have to try to get to.
But your question is right on point. Thanks.
I just wanted to follow up with that comment that, I don't know if it was
yesterday, but Ashley Kean gave an amazing talk on this in terms of
the three-dimensional reconstruction of
fallopian tubes and location of lesions throughout the tubes.
It was fantastic.
And I also-- just one other comment about that.
I think it's awesome that there are so many STICs, and if we're able
to find them, because then you could imagine we could
find out something by doing some sort of
phase zero study where women agree to take some sort of
STIC blocking thing or whatever, and we look and see what it does to STICs once
we're able to reliably find them. So the fact that everybody has STICs is something
that we should leverage to develop a STIC
interception protocol.
Hi, my question's for Dr. Belcher.
I think I saw that you were imaging your fallopian tubes around 800,
900 nanometers, and I was curious if there was any plans to follow up on what
molecules might be exciting at that wavelength?
Because I believe those are like NAD FADs, which would suggest a
metabolism shifting in the cells of interest there.
Yeah. So, really good question.
Our initial screens were at
two different wavelengths,
808 and 980,
and we were picking those because we developed technology
in the past to look deep
inside the cells with light.
That technology we're using right now is not
looking at the cellular level, but is looking at
scanning the tubes and looking at
differences across the tube. So we don't actually know,
unless we have a marker there, like the
fluorescent marker,
what
is in those cells. But what we have done since then
is
take those cells that we've looked at,
collected, and grown into culture, and
looked in detail at different wavelengths of light,
and have started to look at interesting
changes at the subcellular level, which I did not talk about
today. But it's a really good
question. Most of all, we're also looking at different
polarization, and most of all, what we're looking at is
differences in
water content and lipid content, and such.
It's a good point. I'd love to talk a little bit more about it.
And then we just have two more minutes and there's three online questions.
One is, would increased Cascade genetic testing help with increased uptake of
opportunistic salpingectomy?
Yes, of course. I think because if we are able
to identify folks at increased risk, then women can sort of
plan for, "Well, if I'm at increased risk and I happen to be having my last
kid, instead of a tubal ligation, I'd get a salpingectomy." And then,
whether you still have to plan on ovaries, hopefully, will be answered by the
large US, UK, and international trials that are
ongoing.
Are patients who receive ectopic pregnancy removal via salpingectomy
candidates for the imaging study?
Not this protocol that we're working on because it is
just folks who have
anatomically normal appearing fallopian tubes, which would not be in
the setting of an ectopic. And then, is there data showing that
sticks may often be localized to a certain portion of the fallopian tube, just
embed the tube with different orientation to see more?
And I think that had come up and we know from some of the work that
obviously Rani and Yiming have done that,
and just as we spoke, if you flip the block into a different orientation and you
section it more, you will find more.
So it's there, it's just a matter of how much we look.
Thanks, everyone. Don't forget your tubes